what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting
to something one of my subscribers sent
to me on instagram
houdini and the city of the fallen
rappers if you guys want to submit clips
from
for me to react to follow me on
instagram and send me
the videos there before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel
as you guys know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers it's a big goal for the
channel and each and every one of you
helps okay and also while you're at it
ring the notification bell
um because that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
not only okay
teeny in the city you become a target
not only you're a target you're rapping
about these people
your house is ten times the size of a
house that would make me dislike me
if i was on the other side
ah i don't need you when i needed myself
i was a national body for help she
wanted me cause the name ring and bells
designer the g so designer
he was just like my favorite rapper
literally of anyone he was my favorite
when you really think about it yeah most
artists do get killed
in their their home city and why do you
think that is
hatred people looking at you saying i
wish that was me
bullets sent many fleeing for their
lives here on this stretch
now the 21 year old has been identified
as a popular toronto
rapper all right we gotta talk about the
houdini story right the jealousy and
hatred rappers gotta deal with
in their own home city is terrible and
that's a fact in every state
in america but one of the most violent
cities right now for up-and-coming
rappers to make it out
of is toronto and people don't realize
this there's a reason
i'm surprised too toronto like you don't
think of toronto as
super toronto's becoming one of the most
surveyed cities in north america it's
looking like beijing they're getting
cameras everywhere only atlanta chicago
and dc got more surveillance per person
and that's because of the ongoing gang
war that's been escalating for
years right it's literally hunting
season on rappers
and that's exactly what happened to
houdini houdini was sitting down with
record labels i'm gonna lie guys
i have no idea who houdini is was in l.a
in new york
collabing with pop smoke this kid was
the real deal
until a couple weeks ago he was brutally
shot and killed
in broad daylight in the entertainment
district of downtown toronto and this
[ __ ] was surgical they used
glock 9s with 30 round mags they took
advantage of corona season by wearing
medical masks to hide their faces
there was a six-year-old kid that got
caught in the crossfire
dodging bullets that has a high capacity
magazine it's a 30 round magazine and as
this unfolds
i want you to pay attention to the
little boy that ducks into the vestibule
here the whole thing was nuts right and
the city is shook right now
now we're gonna get into all this but
before we do my song of the day today is
none other than houdini himself
let's go ain't killing money music
that's like vvvvs
[Music]
does anyone have statistics maybe
they're gonna go through that in this
video but i'd be really curious to see
how come like if you have 10 up and
coming rappers like similar to his size
how common is it that they're like
killed in something and what factors
like influence that
is it like are they already involved in
gangs or is it
something that happens like when they
get used to flipping the whole patterns
[Music]
all right in order to understand this
story we gonna focus on one hood
in particular in toronto called
driftwood or north side jane and finch
and this is where houdini's from
now they're by far the most influential
in terms of music
in the city but they're also a notorious
[ __ ] faction right they beef with pretty
much everybody in the city
to the south of them the south side of
jain and finch they bang
blood and that's their direct rivals the
lowest income neighborhood in the city
called regent
also has tension with driftwood stemming
from
rat beefs and rap killings and another
area called rexdale
has been driftwood's rival for damn near
a decade now so they beefed with
everybody now in 2015
driftwood kids kinda instilled the
shyrack music vibe
up in the north in canada they were
putting disses to rivals in their tracks
and talking about the stuff they were
doing in the streets
in their lyrics if you diss my [ __ ]
then you know we pulling triggers late
nights with them killers we kidnapping
drugs
now that song is robert banks featuring
presa press is one of the few who
actually crossed over to the mainstream
american scene and he's actually living
in cali right now
in a nice mansion his rap career popped
off for him but
before all that he was involved in a
case where
he allegedly kidnapped two drug dealers
moving them around from
location to location holding them for
ransom until eventually
forcing them to give each other head in
front of everybody
two dudes that's crazy now oh my god
that's so gross
that's so i
cannot believe they would do that that's
so
mean oh my god
oh i'm not gonna sleep well tonight oh i
don't like it alpresa was later clear to
those charges and
granted the court's permission to go on
tour with drake out in england and
another rapper got six years in press's
place
for the charge now press's partner robin
banks who is in that track that i just
showed
he was practically the pioneer for the
scene right he had the torch early
on from 2015 and he kind of started this
organic
hood label in driftwood where he was
putting on all the rappers from his area
robin banks started getting millions of
views
caught the attention of mick mill who
really rock with the movement meek mill
and robert banks were
sending paperwork back and forth he was
about to sign a deal with the dream
chasers
and to celebrate he was having a party
at a hookah lounge called cameo where
unfortunately
his ops found out about it infiltrated
the party
and shot him up nine times leaving him
in critical condition
just as this man was about to cross over
to the us scene they orchestrated that
hit on now thankfully
robert banks is alive but he's paralyzed
from the neck down and his ops were
super disrespectful posting memes of him
in a wheelchair and stuff
he's still doing his thing releasing
tracks and of course pushing the rappers
from driftwood on his label
but the rivals going after robert banks
like that really escalated the violence
in the city and it made it kind of a
trophy for people to target rappers this
was like the first
high profile assassination attempt on a
rapper who was about to cross over now
the next year
the most influential artist so it sounds
like just from my understanding and let
me know if i'm right in the comments it
sounds like
they were involved in this stuff before
they got famous
and then as they're popping off that
just
made an even bigger target come on their
back because
well like you know jealousy
out of the country was smoked now i'm
not from toronto you don't gotta be from
toronto to no smoke dog he was getting
co-signed by
drake doing shows in the uk in the us
and he's from the place called
regent park now this is pretty much the
trenches right it's the lowest income
community in the whole city but it's not
very close to driftwood and because of
that
they didn't really have too much tension
back and forth
until one summer night at a club in 2018
smoke dog got into a heated
argument with a driftwood rapper by the
name of 21 neat
and this [ __ ] escalated quickly right
they stepped outside where 21 neat
how did these beefs initially start
because he just said like he got into
a b for altercation whatever
does someone say something disrespectful
or how does
how does it like rip someone off rob
them like how does this typically stop
shot and killed smoke dog and his
manager probably one of the most
gruesome after death videos i've seen of
a rapper right people were filming him
and smoke dog's brain matter was like
leaking on the road
it was a wild scene now this pretty much
gave regen the green light
to go after driftwood as retaliation and
this created
a whole bunch of new way all these gifts
okay all these gifts and blessed souls
and inner city lights being extinguished
lately is devastating i wish peace
would wash over our city so much talent
and so many stories
we never get to see play out rest up
smoke problems in the city where two
neighborhoods that otherwise
didn't have too much tension now have
maximum levels of tension and driftwood
didn't really care like they were
welcoming all smoke now the toronto
police didn't arrest the rapper 21
neat for quite some time they couldn't
find him there were even rumors that he
escaped to somalia but
he eventually got found out all the way
out in the west coast of the country
near vancouver where he was extradited
back to toronto to stand trial for the
murder of smoke dog
now this is when the story gets wild
because 21 neat has a brother who goes
by the name of 22ne
right they're both from driftwood
they're from the same block as presa
robin banks they're all homies which is
why it was weird when everyone found out
five months ago in december of 2019 22
neat killed his own homie
and fellow rapper on their label named
yes
had just gotten back from doing a bit in
jail and he was on a bunch of tracks
that were getting hundreds of thousands
of views
and out of nowhere the feds found ys
body all the way out on the west coast
of the country
near vancouver and the rumors started
circulating that 22 neet his own homie
was the one who pulled the trigger
nobody really knows why he did it but
some people say it was over money
that's not been confirmed anyways 22
neat knew there would be repercussions
so there's a lot of this stuff over
money i'm kind of new to like rapper
beef let me know in the comments he fled
to a place called
calgary alberta but he didn't last long
they actually found him dead
two days later as revenge for what he
did to the homie ys
now at this point the city's in crisis
and driftwood was putting out all this
talent but this horrific stuff kept
happening
is nobody afraid of death like
i don't know if i if i was about to do
any of this stuff
i would think hmm do i want to die
not really honestly i mean but maybe
they don't
care yeah 30 30. the next to pop out of
the city was this rap duo
formed by two brothers from driftwood
known as the talib twins
they had this track with five million
views that was
scorching hot in the city and in the us
as well before one of the twins
eventually got locked up
so the other twin decided to keep the
momentum going and kept releasing these
fire tracks
under the name the talib twin in
february of 2020
the talib twin was at a condo party on
the 32nd floor
of an airbnb rental when two of his ops
infiltrated the party
and started opening fire the taliban
fired back and managed to kill both of
them before he himself
died at the scene and there's a bunch of
speculation as to what happened i mean
you can't make this [ __ ] up right like
some people say
he tripped and shot himself why are
the only two why only only two are
considered murders as a mystery there
have not been whispers
or there have been whispers that one may
have shot himself but police are not
but the feds believe he went into
another room in the condo
and just ended his own life like the
story is crazy and
the thing with driftwood and the
politics in the city is they beef
with so many places that sometimes it's
hard to say
who is responsible for targeting they
got a lot of enemies and then of course
at the end of may the single biggest
name out of toronto who's not drake or
tory lanez or the weeknd
was the rapper houdini now as i said in
my intro this is a kid who is sitting
down with
record labels in new york and los
angeles he was going to go places
but unfortunately as the trend is in the
city houdini was in the entertainment
district of toronto
late in the afternoon and little did he
know there was a volkswagen tiguan that
was
lying in weight on the east side of a
street called blue jays way which is
right
where he had to go by they were waiting
for a long time
over 40 minutes and houdini was with a
15 year old boy
at the time and they were making their
way down the street and once they got in
range of the volkswagen a lone shooter
got out of the vehicle and started
unloading a bunch of clips in houdini's
direction there was this little kid who
was
caught in the crossfire as well as a
family like this whole thing is on
cctv footage right it's heart-wrenching
they unloaded a bunch of clips in the
houdini who
got hit and kept running right
adrenaline even if you get wounded
mortally you could still run cause you
got adrenaline so he was running
with a bunch of bullets in his body and
then eventually collapsed
and died the fifteen-year-old kid who
was with houdini was also strapped and
he was
trying to get off shots back at the
assailants and then his gun jammed right
which he got rid of in an alleyway
and ran away now meek mill tory lanes
and a whole bunch of others took the
social media to express their
condolences as soon as this happened
and you could see just how much the
industry was rocking with houdini like
this was a kid who was about to make it
but just look at toronto
the city is in shambles right now the
retaliation killings have already been
ordered houdini's own memorial got shot
up
in this ridiculous video you can see on
youtube it's like this drive-by style
video where
out of the darkness this car pulls up
starts opening fire into a crowd the
whole crowd is strapped up so they
immediately start firing back but
this [ __ ] is nuts i know this happens in
the states it's nothing new but
i'm coining toronto wait this
this does not happen close to where i
live the city of the fallen rappers
because
the trend recently of the up and coming
rappers who are now dead
is just unparalleled like you can't
compare it but yeah man that's it for
this video
rest in peace to houdini okay
i did not enjoy that at all i cannot get
the
image of them forcing two straight guys
to sucky
oh god oh god and the little boy oh
god um i did not enjoy that
if you did let me know in the comments
don't forget to subscribe i will talk to
you guys
next time